you there boy what day is it why it's
friday sir
it's one division one division
one division okay so episode three ended
with a cliffhanger that even hawkeye
didn't see coming
and we closed out with monica being
tossed out faster than the inhumans
after that terrible first series this
entry flips the script to answer a lot
of questions that we have over the show
i absolutely love it when a film or
series does this
whether it's the two towers opening with
a perspective of gandalf
lost showing us the plane crash from the
view of the others or back to the bloody
future 2
showcasing morty not trying to bone his
mum again
it always feels like it adds a lot of
context as always we're gonna be
breaking it all down but if this is your
first time here i'm your host paul
and i just want to give a huge thank you
for getting our breakdowns trending on
youtube two weeks in a row
i love you three thousand now let's get
into the spoilers
okay so monica rambo is someone that i
feel we need to talk about in general
before we get into what happens in the
episode itself
her debut in the mcu actually happened
all the way back in the 1990s
when we saw her as a kid in captain
marvel starring brie larson
nick fury clearly had his eye on her
mother we find out in the episode that
she was a founder of sword
and then monika got the job through
knowing her prob
probably had some qualifications too she
will of course be going on to be more in
line with her comic book counterpart
which we'll now be discussing in general
as always though time codes are below if
you want to just skip ahead to the
breakdown
but the next part of the video kind of
fills in the who's who of the big names
now under the name photon moniker is
able to modulate her own energy to
change her appearance so that she can
look like anyone she wants
monika can also fly fire energy blasts
and absorb the energy of things around
her
she also possesses superhuman speed can
turn invisible
and phase through solid matter not to
jump too far ahead but we know that she
will be featuring
alongside ms marvel and carol danvers
and captain marvel 2
so expect to see a lot more from her in
the marvel universe
now alongside her is fbi agent jimmy wu
who he last saw in ant-man in the wasp
the guy was fascinated by magic and i
don't need to
spell it out that wonder bewitched what
but clearly in that film he was assigned
to look after scott because he broke the
sokovia records
similar to this wanda did too and it's
even possible that he was shifted to her
after lang because of his job in general
it turns out that he was actually the
voice on the other end of the radio
and has been desperately trying to save
not only moniker but the town's folk as
well
on top of the pair we also discovered
more about the enigmatic beekeeper
and initially there were theories that
he was going to turn into swarm
though this could be the case for now he
stands more as a demonstration
of how the ins and outs of the bubble
work i absolutely
love things being shown to us from
sword's perspective and though this is
never said in the entry
the fact that they were chosen over
shield could hint out what's going on in
the series itself
due to the commercials it's long been
speculated that hydra have something to
do with wonder being trapped
and that they along with agnes and
mephisto are behind it all
this was hinted at by the struck a watch
the hydra soak
and phil holding a newspaper in a way in
which hydrant looked like hydra
the last time we saw them in the mcu was
when mitchell carson was running off
with darren cross's pin particle
and we already know from the falcon in
the winter soldier trailer that they're
making a big comeback
like the inhuman should wow wow as we
learned in the winter soldier
hydra actually infiltrated shield and
thus it makes sense why sword would be
chosen over them
nick fury's journey during the
post-credits scene of far from home was
traveling through space which is
typically the type of mission that sword
go on
but that could be me reaching and maybe
they're just on earth
potentially though hydro want to weapon
nice wonder and may be using her own
powers to create a bath like simulation
in which he's trapped
after doing a binge watch of the mcu
recently i noticed that the ending of
avengers end game
basically had a very similar aesthetic
to one division with both her and steve
traveling back to a 1950s alternate
reality to be with the one that they
love
thus they could possibly be using this
notion to make her do their evil bidding
but we'll of course discuss that later
in the video now speaking of end game
paul bettany actually revealed something
earlier this week that could have sealed
the
vision in imdb's ask each other anything
he revealed that there was a
post-credits scene at the end of the
movie that had wonder unzipping a body
bag with vision in it
[ __ ] cut the scene as we now know but
that doesn't mean that it won't pop up
again down the line
perhaps showing one of the heartbreaking
reasons that led to the events of the
season
now as for the episode itself we open
with monaco waking up in a hospital
after recovering from the blip
we later learned that her mother maria
died two years after the snap
and thus she spent the time after that
not truly knowing what happened to her
daughter
though she held out hope she would
return it's so impactful how from
monica's perspective
she was sat next to her mother in bed as
she was just about to be discharged
and then in the next second she was gone
the opening is amazing and it truly
brings the full weight that one would
feel if something like this actually
happened
so far we've only really seen the good
side of the blip but the panicking
confusion that happens here is
astounding
and it's one of the best openings in an
mcu property ever
i loved watching her realize that her
mother had passed away and that she now
had to attempt to return to a normal
life
though it would be impossible we cut to
the sentient weapon observation response
division
or sword for short to find monica
returning to her job to find that her id
has expired
on a news report we can see a mother and
daughter hugging with the headline the
blip brings back loved ones
this is of course a slap in the face to
monica as both she and her mother should
have been reunited like the people in
the picture
but they were cheated out of their last
goodbye by thanos
if maria had been taken instead or along
with monica
then they would have got some time
together to finally say farewell
and it just feels completely depressing
in the show
that's already slightly depressing now
here we meet acting director tyler
hayward
who pretty much becomes the kind of
authoritative figure
that these fed dramas are full of a cool
little point that comes from him
is he actually plays into one of the fan
theories slightly and the clues that
have been given to us so far throughout
the series it's been theorized that
everyone other than wonder is acting
and this was cemented by vision who said
that the whole world is a stage
moniker initially calls him director
which he corrects to acting director
perhaps being a cute little nod to
what's going on in the show overall
we see a plaque for maria whose nickname
was of course also
photon hinting to us the direction that
her daughter could be going when filling
in her shoes
maria is pretty much the peggy carter of
her organization
and similar to peggy she met a captain
that inspired her to build a law
enforcement agency
we learned monica is also the first to
report in and everyone else is likely
taking a break
probably to be with their family sword
used to be investigating space travel
but since the blip took out half the
staff they pointed their eyes to earth
instead
there's some sort of awkwardness between
the pair as monica should have named her
mother's replacement
but because of the snap she wasn't able
to perhaps meaning that there may be
some bad blood between the two down the
line
maria implemented guidelines to keep the
vanished returned on earth
and nurse moniker as hell back from
doing things that she wants to
probably because her mother sort of
wanted to look after her
from beyond the grave creepy now behind
tyler we can also see a circular map
which juxtaposes the hexagonal ones that
we see in west view later
showing the differences between the
realities very subtly
hexagons have of course appeared
throughout the season so far
and wonders powers in the comics are in
fact called hex
2. therefore monika is saying that
wonder is the one doing it
does make a lot of sense but we'll talk
about how that might be a misdirect
later in the video
monica is sent on a missing person's
mission that turns into a missing town
one
and it's at this point that we get a
proper view of west view from the
outside
and we've already broken down the west
view sign for having the initials w and
v which stands for wonder and vision
and for having the letters tv in the
middle of it however
the slogan of the town also reads home
it's where you make it
which of course ties into how wonder has
made her home and the fake reality there
we can also see that monika has a sword
id badge around her neck and because of
this we can assume that certain items of
clothing
are transformed upon entering the
reality just in the same way that the
hazmat suit became a beekeeper outfit
monika's badging id transformed into the
sword necklace that we saw in episode 3.
here she meets jimmy
boosting out the tricks that you learned
from ant-man and also
two police officers who don't seem to
know what's going on
claiming that they come from east view
now to me this highlights that there's
also force on the outside controlling
their brains and what they perceive
as wonder wouldn't be able to do this a
similar thing happened in the book it by
stephen king
as pennywise was actually able to
mentally influence the adults
so that they didn't look too deeply into
the missing children it's extremely
similar here with the police being
completely nonchalant about the
vanishing town
almost like they've been mind controlled
which they definitely have
now jimmy brings up that he's looking
after a missing person from the witness
protection program
and we don't actually learn who this is
it is said that it's a man
and it could be ralph who has been
missing from the show itself
may also be norm as he was called a
communist and though
not a missing person he did seem very
suspicious
now early on i got a lot of x-file vibes
and if the show is aping other tv series
so far
i would say that this is the closest
thing that this episode pulls from
monica sends in a drone and as we
predicted in episode 2
the helicopter was indeed one of these
it disappearing makes monica put her
hand in the membrane
and she mustn't have seen alien because
look stick in your face and stuff
it's the last thing you want to do jimmy
goes for help and we are reintroduced to
wisecracking darcy played by kat
dennings
due to her experience in thor and
astrophysics
she's been brought in to help to get to
the bottom of what's going on
as we know the ending of the dark world
dealt with going through multiple
realities and dimensions
and that she has experience to pick up
the correct signals
she was actually the person watching the
tv at the end of episode 1
and has been scanning things for clues
bringing everything together
now at the sword response space we watch
as their plan seems to be
just losing drones but darcy hooks up to
an old physio scope to tune into the
frequencies of the show
this is made by lexington instruments
which could be a nod to alexander
lexington
a mutant in the marvel universe slowly
they piece together the identities of
the town folk
and these provide some major clues now
dottie is not in the lineup at all
perhaps suggesting that she isn't
actually a member of the town
and is one of the big bads potentially
the grim reaper
mephisto or nightmare going with the
latter two
the villains could be using the twins as
a way to manifest
into physical form so that they can
enter the mc reality
as until now they've existed solely in
their own planes
however this could also be a red herring
as dottie didn't appear until the second
episode
and the photos that we see are only from
episode one perhaps
leading us astray when we should be
focusing on someone else
that is agnes unlike the rest she's
missing id
and therefore i think the theory that
she is agatha harkness gains a lot more
weight
if sword were unable to track her down
it's likely because she wanted to lie
low
and never register with any
organizations due to her immortality
agatha has lived for centuries and it is
possible that she met with wonder
and showed her how to boost their powers
in order to create this new dimension
in the first episode she told us that
her wedding anniversary with ralph
was on the 2nd of june and this is
actually the day that the first salem
witch trials took place
it is possible as these began she
pledged her allegiance to the dark lord
mephisto
and there are a number of other clues
i've covered this in a lot more detail
on other videos and don't want to just
retread all ground
but she did say that ralph looks better
in the dark also make sure that no one
knows i called herb
ralph in the last video because that
would make me look like a right idiot
wouldn't it
now they ask the questions that we've
been doing all along which is a nice
little touch that shows marvel knew what
the main talking points would be
we can also tell from the driving
licenses and monica driving in
that west view is indeed in new jersey
which has long been theorized
it's nice to have the location finally
confirmed and it's very close to the
base that we saw in avengers endgame
though difficult to make out there is a
bit of text on everyone's name that
basically asks if wonder is controlling
the whole town
i know this question it does seem like
it gets an answer at the end
i don't think that she fully is there's
also mr hart who we learn is called todd
davis
which is actually the name of an extra
from iron man 3 but beyond that i
couldn't find anything else
now another interesting element is the
colorization of the drone
which perhaps shows that sometimes
wonder loses her control over the
reality
and is unable to hold everything in
place this of course happened with the
blood on doddy's hand
showing that when she's distracted it is
possible to beat her
though she can always reset things in
the sewers we follow the beekeeper
and his fate still remains unknown we
know that he wasn't sent outside of the
bubble
and that the time he spent inside there
was erased so perhaps he's been
transformed into something else
if the theories about him being swarm or
true then this would be an amazing
origin story
as the villain pretty much exists as a
swarm of bees
most of the time meaning that is mad at
could have been highly altered by such
an occurrence
kurta darcy and wu sharing chips and the
ladder talks about having babies himself
not gonna lie here kind of hope these
characters hook up at some point
but i guess we're gonna see last week we
did wonder why we never saw the clip of
monica being thrown out of the reality
as it was in the trailer however we
finally get it shown here as we switch
perspectives back to wonder
who not only erases time but also
manifests her powers to send monica
flying out of the dome monica also has
octagon earrings
which juxtaposes the idea of hexagons
hammering home that
she was opposed to the pocket dimension
in some way now as mentioned earlier
rambo does eventually become photon in
the comics and i actually have a theory
that when she was hit with wanda's
powers
and then thrown out of the membrane that
she gained these abilities
and will have them going forward a lot
of photons power set including the
ability to change appearance
are all things that we've seen
demonstrated in this pocket dimension
with the shifting of time periods
thus it could be possible that wanda's
power and the reality have merged
together into her
making her close to a comic book
counterpart on the outside she says it's
wonder
but i think that this is a misdirect to
make us think that it is
a lot of the time things have just been
forced on her such as the heavily
speeded of pregnancy
and basically a lot of the major plot
points
just after throwing moniker out of the
reality we can also see some giraffe
statues
giraffes are actually born with the
ability to stand up unlike a lot of
animals
and this hints to the hastiness of the
cycle that the twins went through
hinting to me that someone or something
is subliminally influencing her to carry
things out
she also sees vision as he was when he
died which to me paints her out as more
of a victim of her own trauma
rather than the big bad that a lot of
people think she is
in general i feel that villains have to
be evil
whereas wanda really isn't she's someone
struggling with the mental health issues
and despair that comes with grief
and has likely been manipulated there is
of course five more episodes left as
well
so i can't see the big reveal that she's
the body coming this early on
and we will likely have a lot more going
forward we close out to voodoo child by
jimi hendrix
hinting to her power and that she may be
running the show from now on
for quite a while however whilst this
play she also picks up one of her kids
and to me this sort of symbolizes the
occult theory that mephisto is wanting
to take over their body
now as for the episode as a whole i
thought it was incredible you know
from the opening i was absolutely hooked
and it was just such a good way to
handle the severity of the consequences
of not only the snap
but also bringing everyone back i think
this was easily the strongest of the
episodes thus far
and seeing things through the eyes of
someone on the ground level trying to
adjust to missing five years of their
life
was a brilliant choice now that we have
the added context of what's going on
i think we will have a much better
appreciation for the show
i also think retroactively it will make
the past episodes even better now that
we have more
answers both darcy and jimmy were also
some inspired choices to follow
and i love the lighthearted touches of
wit that they brought whilst dealing
with the severity of the events
episode 4 was amazing and this show has
me fully hooked now
i think that this is an incredible entry
okay so for the next part of the video
we will be talking about some of the
spoilers that have been posted
so make sure you click out of the
breakdown if you don't want anything
ruined
this was actually posted by disney
themselves during a making up video on
the series
and it does seem to hint at where things
could be going
now in the background of this image we
can clearly see wonder man
and fans of the comic the vision and
skull at witch will know that he plays a
pivotal arc in that book
the story itself is somewhat inspiring
the events of the show
as we already know that the grim reaper
is featuring in it and his brother is
actually simon williams
aka wonder man so things do link
together quite well
now i have heard a lot of theories at
the vision we see might actually be
wonder man
and that the grim reaper has brought him
back to life through his brother's body
which he is unaware of inhabiting in the
source material
vision's mind was actually a duplicate
of wonder man's brain
and this could be carried across here
though we won't know for definite
until it's actually revealed now huge
shout outs to heil hydra on my last
video for sending me down this rabbit
hole
and after investigating it further i do
think that it lines up
wonder man actually has a lot of the
same skill set as vision has
but he possesses super speed before this
series
vision never moved faster than a
speeding bullet and it did seem odd that
he was suddenly able to do this
when we hadn't seen it before it would
have been super useful when trying to
avoid thanos's forces and hey
maybe he is actually in wonder man's
body and just doesn't realize it yet
now whether this turns out to be true or
not i don't know
i think it does tie in with the comics
but marvel may be misleading us on
purpose
we've all seen the fake shots that they
drop in trailers and i'll never forget
the the hulk at the end of infinity war
you won't you won't fool me again
now i have been long thinking that when
this reality collapses that vision will
go with it too
but this could be a way of keeping him
around and it also means that paul bear
and he doesn't have to cake himself in
beetroot juice
every single day there were also some
leaked young avengers funko's posted
that seem to show what could be the team
as well as wiccan and speed in their
full costumes
however i'm not sure whether these are
fan made or not but i do think they're
worth talking about
just in case they aren't now and of
course love to hear your thoughts on
these leaks
and what theories you take from them and
obviously we won't know until they're
revealed in the show itself
but it's always fun to speculate and say
where you think things will be going
there's also the episode itself which
i'd love to hear your thoughts on
and as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
straw on the 30th of january in which
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit and lord of the rings 4k box sets
to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
some of the theories on what's going on
in the show
or episode three which will be linked on
screen right now
without the way thanks for sitting
through the video i hope you enjoy the
weekend
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time you better be back yeah
promise me that take care peace
[Music]